this episode is brought to you by Target
so you want to blow up a few planets
what character are fully armed and
operational battle station should you
use will treat all footage like it's
real video evidence make physicists
study it to extract hard numbers on
their attributes then have them compete
in a challenge of our own design to
crown one the most powerful
[Music]
this is power levels today's competitors
are two Titans of terror the first Death
Star from Star Wars a new hope and
Thanos from the end for you for our
challenges we'll have to destroy the
earth Mars and Jupiter in that order
whoever destroys each planet the fastest
gets a point
whoever or whatever has the most points
at the end of the challenge is crowned
the most powerful a few ground rules the
Death Star has to travel to just outside
each planet they can't wait until all
their orbits line up and do it in one
shot in our Thanos is the one from the
beginning of infinity wars so he only
has two of the five stones space which
lets him travel instantaneously and
power which lets him send out energy
blasts and manipulate matter from a
distance sorry
no snapping the galaxy out of reality
clear three let's go first we should
discuss how to blow up the world when
you throw a ball into the air on earth
you give it some kinetic energy but the
earth is so massive its gravity brings
it back towards the center of mass our
competitors will have to use their
powers to treat each atom of the planet
like that ball but they'll have to throw
them so hard they escape the planets
gravitational field and never come back
down again we'll call this the
gravitational potential energy and to
calculate it we'll build each planet one
thin layer at a time until we reach
their known radius kind of like adding
layers to an onion if you're anything
like me at this point you're wishing you
paid attention in calculus or even made
it to calculus or learn to read read
whatever but at least now we can add up
how much energy is required to blow up
each planet for Jupiter it's 2 times 10
to the 36 joules that's more energy than
the Sun pumps out in a year now to see
how long it would take to destroy each
one we need to figure out the power both
the Death Star and Thanos can generate
power is another way of saying energy
divided by time so let's track down both
of those numbers
starting up the Death Star we know that
Alderaan is roughly the same size as
Earth so we can use Earth's potential
energy as a stand-in for Leia's home
planet now we simply time how long it
takes for the Big D to blow it up and
Wow
that didn't take long by dividing its
energy by that time we arrive at a power
output of 6.2 times 10 to the 32nd
joules per second how much power is that
about the same as 400 octillion
teakettles
now let's check on Santos his most
impressive feat with the power stone is
when he throws the surface of a moon at
Robert Downey jr. how big is that moon
it's not easy to figure out given the
shots we have to work with the minimum
diameter of a round object in space is
about 700 kilometres so it's at least
that big and the largest would be if we
assume the moon was the same size as
tight
50 100 kilometres across because he's
like a total daddy well give him the
benefit of the doubt and go at the
bigger number we looked at multiple
shots of the moon toss and estimated he
rips off about 5% of the crust now we
can calculate how much mass that would
actually be plug it into our equation
for gravitational potential energy
divide that by time and dammuz can
deliver eight times ten to twenty eighth
joules per second with the power stone
to put that in context the energy
released by the Power Stone in one
second can power the world for ten
million years and since Thanos never
runs out of energy and has no harmful
waste products I think we just found the
perfect light bulb hello wait stop for a
second does Santos have waste products
the thinnest poop it's got a mouth and
cooks food so probably but it's gaining
that Thanos absorbs cosmic rays for
energy loop cosmic rays these are my
questions if we assume all cosmic rays
are protons as most of them are we could
calculate how many protons would be
absorbed by Thanos while he's standing
on earth then see how long it would take
to absorb a mass equivalent to the
average poop of 0.1 kilograms if we plug
in the numbers the house would go 200
thousand years between bowel movements
on earth yikes
that is not how
see but if you got hungry and floated
right next to the Sun will assume the
inverse square law and calculate he'd
absorb a Boop sighs math in one
nanosecond he'd fill up with poop faster
than you can snap your fingers okay bad
enough poop science yes No okay back to
the show with the Death Star and Thanos
his energy output in hand we can finally
settle who's the more efficient genocide
Albania starting at earth the Death Star
would destroy us all in point three
seconds just like Alderaan while Thanos
wouldn't kick a comparatively slow forty
four minutes to tear the blue ball apart
giving a big ball one point while that
big ball gets zero now it's on to Mars
for the next point and here's where
things get interesting the time of year
can change these numbers but it would
take an average of four minutes at
Lightspeed for the Death Star to get
from Earth to Mars
well panels get there in the snap of a
finger Thanos takes a jared leto s 60
seconds to blow up Mars
well the Death Star takes 10
milliseconds but when you add in the
travel time Danis finished the job first
and takes the point for the red planet
we're all tied up
finally it's Jupiter's turn it takes the
Death Star an average of 30 minutes at
Lightspeed to arrive Nathanael said zero
will that be enough of a head start for
Danis to win the deciding challenge and
not so much it would take in 318 days
trip Jupiter apart and the Death Star
just one hour even if we tilt the scales
for Thanos and assume the Death Star
takes a full 24 hours to recharge its
main cannon as some more sources do our
final result would still be the same
the Death Star gets the final point and
the lead crowning it our most powerful
that said our scientists tell us that
even if the Death Star were a sphere of
pure energy it would still be physically
impossible for an object of that size to
store what it manages to shoot out sure
you could wave your hand and say Kyber
crystals or antimatter or midi-chlorians
or whatever but I'll sleep well knowing
that the Death Star is just as
unrealistic as the killer magic space
glove and besides Thanos will kick the
Death Star's ass in a straight-up fight
that guy hates losing and moons boom
science what the data doesn't care about
my feelings or life but we care about
you
know who you'd like to see compete next
and you could see them here on the next
episode of power levels
this holiday the toys of a generation of
Star Wars fans come home explore a whole
galaxy of Star Wars toys available at
Target
[Music]
you